welcome everybody to
session 21 of classic metal class now
hosted on this new platform light hall
i'm you know really glad to have scott
here as an expert and we've got some
significant expertise in the people
attending as well so this is i think
they're going to be a really
great discussion about rebellion and
this is one of the really key
themes people have identified as being
part of um you could call it the
lifestyle the the lyrics the mentality
of heavy metal um it figures into for
for good or for for bad into like you
know uh dina weinstein's sociology of
heavy metal the uh the people who tried
to clamp down on heavy metal in the
1980s that's something that they really
paid close attention to so i think
there's a lot to explore here and we've
this is our second thematic episode
where we're looking at lyrics
specifically we did one earlier that's
that some of you were here for
on
songs that have to do with metal
identity
so songs that thematize metal itself and
i think we're gonna hit on a few of
those as well
so rebellion um not unique to metal um i
think you can say that it's an integral
part of
at least some rock and roll there was
this idea
that to like get into rock and roll was
in a certain way to be rebellious
and it could promote behavior that uh
authorities didn't like
so and then you know metal has a big
competitor i think you can say
in the 1970s in punk right
all about rebellion so it's not as if
metal has
the lock on it but we're we're going to
be looking at that
and you know we're all fans of heavy
metal um
i think we can all call ourselves metal
heads
and
is it rebellious so here's a question to
start with before we
prime the pump so to speak
is being a metalhead by its very nature
being rebellious or are there certain
ways of like consuming it participating
in it that are kind of conformist uh not
rebellious and then other modes are
more rebellious what do what all of you
think and scott you can you can go first
with this if you want to well i
we've talked about this in the past um
i i always thought that you know in in
our generation
um the people
uh well i had a unique case in my school
because we didn't have able
so we didn't have mtv we didn't have any
of that stuff so
um me and maybe two other people were
into metal
and um
but
the three of us shared something in
common and that was we were kind of the
misunderstood
bullied um
you know
we fit a certain thing that we
identified with metal you know
metal understood us right where where
other forms of music maybe didn't grab
us uh
maybe it was the intensity it was the
lyric content
yeah
maybe you know the you know heavy metal
did offer a world right so you had the
look if you look at bands like kiss or
iron maiden you know there was more than
just the music there was uh being part
of something the kiss army yeah um and
you know was the kiss army rebellious
well sort of i mean you know
being part of the kiss army may have
been
uh
you know uh may have been kind of an
inspiring thing that you're part of
something but like all of this goes
along with not feeling part of
maybe high school or maybe
the teenage experience at least you know
growing up in the 80s for me
i think it was um
rebellion in the sense that well it was
also i would say finding your own room
if that means yeah
this is this is interesting mark says i
don't think being a metalhead itself so
per se makes you rebellious unless you
want to consider some more conservative
metal listeners as posers even some
metal musicians hardly come across as
rebellious anymore that i mean the time
factor yeah so if we're talking about
the 1970s and 1980s uh when many of us
were quite young and impressionable and
you know like scott said you know angsty
high schoolers looking for belonging and
that sort of thing
that's one thing but you know if you've
been listening to the stuff for
40 years and you go and see a band and
they're in their 70s and they're putting
on a good show
is there any rebelliousness
to that anymore maybe not you know and
now that certain bands became part of
the visual culture so like you see all
these kids walking around in ac dc
metallica iron maiden i forget which
other bands have become quite quite
popular and you go up to them and you
say hey what would you l or def leppard
is a good example yeah you like them and
they're like oh no it's just a t-shirt
you know that's that's a very different
kind of commitment it's no longer in any
way connected to rebellion uh ken says
metals definitely started as a counter
culture but it certainly isn't all that
way today yeah and i wonder if we can
say that already in the 1980s
some of it
was no longer counter cultural
one of the things i was keeping in my
back pocket for a little bit later on
was when i went to monsters of rock and
and that was the kicking off of the 88
tour at alpine valley
um
it was uh kingdom come and everybody
wanted them to get off the stage they
they were really highly regarded and
then it was metallica and then it was
dawkin and then it was the scorpions and
then it was van halen but it was
you know post david lee roth van halen
and people started
alpine valley is this beautiful little
you know venue with with uh uh lots of
grass available
and unfortunately they'd recently sodded
it
and so people started they're a little
bit bored you know they're throwing her
on beach balls and then somebody started
picking up big chunks of sod
and they were throwing it around and
they were throwing it around kind of a
festive way
originally
um and but you know people were getting
like hit with it it was big chunks you
know so like you know weighing 20 pounds
or so
and sammy hager got up there and he
this is this is kind of the funny moment
he said um if you don't stop doing that
we're canceling the rest of the concert
we're not gonna play
and then all these booze oh this isn't
rock and roll you know
and you've sold out but they did stop
and then van halen played their their
set which um by the way did not include
much classic van halen
david lee roth era van halen um it was
mostly you know 5150 and ou 812 and
actually
almost as many sammy hagar songs as
classic van halen
but that struck me as you know as a
17 year old kid watching this i was like
that's not really metal is it
no so we've got some some good
responses mark says to take an extreme
example should we classify neo-nazis who
build their identity around black metal
rebellious and i i would say yes uh and
rebellion could be turned in
multiple ways right
ken's also ken uh followed up on that i
suppose that we could if we consider
rebellion could be good or bad then yes
in a bad way and then oh so rob has also
got his finger on something don't we
have to say something about what
rebellion is a rebellion from or counter
culture too
and so
i don't want to dominate the
conversation
but so let me throw this one to scott
um rebellion and counter culture this is
a good point made by rob these are
relative terms right you can only be
rebellious if you have something to
rebel against so if there's no
counter pressure there's no prevailing
culture giving you a hard time
you're not really a rebel then right
it's well as far as that goes it's
perspective of the person rebelling
right so you can have
you know um okay
you know uh well you know even take the
counterculture thing of high school
um
so metal was a counter culture but you
know i could have had like a it's
possible somebody has a perceived
vision that they're disliked they have a
perceived um or that or they have social
anxieties
so um
so they're projecting out there like
dislike that doesn't really exist or
well yeah i'm kind of like going like
the neo-nazi example is a great one that
is that could be rebellion against
people don't think like them
you know these people so i guess you
know it's a really interesting point uh
is rebellion a rebellion from or a
counterculture
um too yeah counter what i mean yeah
back to the thing it would be to
um it was a very preppy school i mean
just because there was no mtv so
everybody's dressed like it was
that that you know mtv didn't existed so
i was you know with my jean jacket and
ripped jeans and you know
my hair was feathered and i got the
mullet eventually so me too yeah
like a lot of us did
you know um and it was it was it was
more of i would say for me it was more
of a kind of a safe space uh if we want
to call it that or it was it was it was
a world that understood me now not to
abandon what we were saying before
a great point that everybody made here
just a couple minutes ago
i do find it hard to take new metal
um a lot of new metal that like uh
students might show me like
guys in biker shorts
um
or uh
not you know no no kind of world or
image
and i'm looking it's like well you know
they're technically good players but
there's no world here for me to identify
with
that's an interesting way to talk about
it
having to have
a community a world right
yeah i mean that's what metal was it was
it was you know look in the 80s
i just looked up something i should have
i should have sent it to you greg but if
you look on youtube
in 78 gene simmons would do album
signings and every one of them it's like
the newscaster is like i you know i
don't want to be here because i just
want to make it clear i'm not a kiss fan
but you know and then you know
and it he couldn't look any more stuffy
in this one and he goes in and these
kids are going crazy and gene simmons
has given him a hard time
and um so it's it's kind of like well
there's the clear if you look at these
old videos and old interviews there's a
clear counterculture
you know
you know gene simmons uh being you know
a smart aleck and you know the person
going don't you think this is
inappropriate or don't you think this is
going to lead to devil worship or don't
you think well of course
i mean maybe it's a rebellion
well you know there was there was a lot
of that in the let's call it the stuffy
culture right misunderstandings of the
the
genre
um and interestingly too um as has been
pointed out
among academics and music critics metal
was um more or less dismissed all the
way through the 80s you know with a few
exceptions like dina weinstein for
example who has a voice crying out in
the wilderness so there's some some good
disc going on which i think is a great
lead into the first song that we are
going to look at
uh mark says
i obviously wasn't there because mark is
is a bit younger than the rest of us but
a common theme in a lot of early british
metal bands stories is growing up in
post-war industrial areas the
socio-economic circumstances of the
1970s does that bear on the rebellious
theme countering these limitations
um and and yeah i mean i i remember
reading some interesting um interviews
with um
john gallagher uh raven and you know
raven was always kind of a
great but second-tier new wave of
british heavy metal band and he talks
about being poor and going to junkyards
and
um scrounging parts that they could use
to make speakers
and um amps and and things like that you
know
and it's kind of like the punk diy thing
right you know you'd get whatever you
can get your hands on but a lot of it
had to do i think with um scarcity
you you do see that with a lot of these
bands um
you know the famous story about rat and
motley crew having to share an apartment
altogether in the lean years before they
made it big on the sunset strip and then
ken says i think that was essentially
important early 1980s uk was quite
conservative in many ways so the sex
pistols sabbath uh priests and maiden
were seen as a dangerous trend that
could corrupt the youth at the time so
let's let's take about the first song
that i put into our playlist breaking
the law i mean
that is a song of rebellion but it's a
certain kind of rebellion right you look
at the lyrics
and it is um
post-industrial
society there's no place for the guy
right and it's got a great video as well
from the early years of mtv with a band
robbing um
a bank at guitar point guitar point
yeah zooming off in their car you know
um
and you know it's got this anthemic
chorus and i think a lot of the songs of
rebellion are are often anthems aren't
they
so you know breaking the law breaking
the law um i mean i remember my my kids
hearing it and getting into it and then
wandering around the house talking about
breaking the law
um
and so you know what what are these
verses about well i mean look at the
lyrics right he's alienated he's got
anger in his heart he might as well put
some action in his life because his life
sucks
and the motivation seems to be
having been let down there's no place
for me so i'm gonna make a place for me
so rebellion is
um
a way of carving out a
a spot for um himself and there's this
great line that's a bridge point you
don't know what it's like
yeah
that i think is is kind of a whale that
all of us
probably said back then we're rebellious
because you don't know what it's like
for us that well done again that track
i agree i agree you know um
and you know look
we you know i'm sure everybody remembers
this but we do need to point out this is
before you can go
join a social media world and scroll and
when you went home oh you were in the
basement with records man
unless you get somebody hanging out with
you down there well and then but you
know usually anybody hanging out with me
you know somebody bring over the new
david lee roth record or you know
and it would be cranking loud and you
know um
yeah i mean so it's you know
we weren't absorbed into a social media
thing we were absorbed into the records
and you know once you leave school once
you're in the basement you have no clue
what anybody else is doing you know how
you're going to cope you know
that's why
that you nailed it with that you don't
know what it's like
kind of mentality where it's like you
know misunderstood you know or not
understood
yeah and so therefore rebelling against
that right uh mark says breaking the law
is also kind of archetypical i feel
being down and out needing to do some
less than reputable things just to get
by feeling like giving a finger to
anyone who wants to take your slice away
so yeah you could say it's a it's an
economic song of the downtrodden right
instead of just saying well i guess i'll
work my nine to five and that's gonna
suck i can't even get a nine to five i
have to move from town to town
you know
i mean you know
i i guess now we're talking about who
beyond it who would identify with this
tune i think that's what mark's saying
it's not
that's where it gets really interesting
right because and this goes to some of
the points that were being made a little
bit earlier about you can turn rebellion
in different ways
um
i think there were a lot of people who
are like i just like to break laws this
is a great song
i like to vandalize um
i like to steal you know i had some
buddies that would actually break into
trains and uh steal stuff from them and
most of the time it wasn't anything
useful that they could sell
you know um but they they love doing it
and i think it was part of the the
thrill of having to out with the
railroad cops and
getting over us right
yeah um now ken has a good good thing
here about iron maiden we're going to
we're going to talk about running free
in just a bit the maiden album killers
from 81 um if every you know everybody's
probably seen this that's the one where
the eddie has the axe right um and he
looks a little bit more put together
than the eddie from the original
iron maiden album the arms of the person
eddie is just axe feature the sleeves
and cuff of a woman's blouse the style
of blouse is very popular at the time
with none other than then president
prime minister
margaret thatcher the original album
cover by derek riggs allegedly showed
who it was that the eddie was in the
process of killing but it was changed as
the band felt the album could be
banned and and that touches on something
we're going to get into in a bit as well
the the counter response from the
prevailing culture we're not going to
let you
do this sort of stuff and that's
actually a good good lead into the
second um
song we're not going to take it by
twisted sister and there's two versions
of the video right there's there's a
version
where uh it's just the kid
in his his bedroom and he's he's
listening to a twisted sister song he's
got a guitar he's kind of air strumming
along with it and then there's this
longer one that's got like a two-minute
vignette with this guy i don't know who
the actor was but he's actually quite
good
um being this this prick dad who fought
in vietnam didn't come back here to have
his son listening to this crap
he gets excused from the table he goes
upstairs right and then there's all this
stuff for like uh twist you know he he
asks his son you know he goes into this
tirade and he's like um what do you want
you know and then the kid gets to
finally talk and he says i want to rock
which is the twisted sister song that's
playing and he strums the guitar and the
dad gets blown out the window
and then twisted sister appears
and you know they're
you could say judas priest and breaking
the law okay they look like ruffians
right yeah
twisted sister is a whole different
level you got the the drag the makeup
the crazy hair on d snider
imagine somebody like that breaking into
your
your place right and it's it's like a
fever dream that we as kids could look
at and be like yeah that's
that would be awesome right
and um
in a way this is more generic
than
in terms of rebellion than breaking the
law
because it you know it's it's uh got
this course we're not going to take it
oh we're not going to take it we're not
going to take it anymore
what aren't they going to take well i
mean the lyrics tell us some of the
things
um
this is our life we're going to fight
the powers don't pick our destiny okay i
want to decide for myself
you're so condescending your goal is
never-ending we don't want anything from
you
if you're if that's your best your best
won't do it because we're rejecting the
prevailing culture but when he was when
he was asked about this in uh an
interview at one time
d snyder
actually said um
it can be about anything and this is
actually from from this this great book
um
by robert walzer running with the devil
power gender and madness and heavy metal
music he says uh as d snyder twisted
sister says of the song it's very
general we weren't specific about just
what it is we aren't taking work school
whatever so you can apply it to whatever
you want now was that kind of a smart
move on their part lyrically speaking to
make it so open
what do you think i i think oh
absolutely because i mean
even at the time
um
the only parts i could recite of the
song even though i heard it a million
times is the chorus and the brig
we'll fight
we're right you'll see right
yeah but i you know like the verses are
kind of like that wasn't the the part i
responded to so
i mean it it was um
you know it was at a time
when it was starting to get you know
this this culture was coming out it was
like we like you said it's being you
know uh
panned by
anybody that the in the art you know in
the art section of any paper they're
getting and then
you know uh it was the beginning and
like i've always said of
all the movies you know like footloose
and breakfast club and all these things
that were the teens against the parents
and that was really
kind of the theme and you know um
yeah
and
yeah that's interesting because
the kids in footloose for example
and maybe a couple other those movies
if they weren't in such a completely
repressive town they would be the high
school
kids who were
being jerks to the punks and new waivers
and heavy metal people
right
yeah and yeah i mean it was ultra
repressive right yeah so so i mean this
shows the what would we call it the
relativity of of rebellion you know yeah
some some kid in a pickup truck and you
know who wants to dance in his jeans and
and button-down shirt
um and where was it that that he was
dancing and something must be business
no no i'm thinking in footloose he was
dancing in some barn right
yeah yeah i mean he's he's the
he's not the guy who's going to be
showing up to a twisted sister concert
um but like i mean you know i guess the
the the town was almost hyperbolic in
the in how stiff it was yeah you know
it's so it was really supposed to you
know we would go there you know and then
of course you know mr roboto comes out
about the same thing
right uh kill right yeah
yeah which which which tanked what was
like you know going on the backs of the
it was a cool record that's for sure
there's a lot of stuff that tank that
that um we did respond to now mark has
uh two two points here
so from a songwriting perspective uh
we're not going to take it as great it's
lack of specificity makes it an anthem
you can carry it all over the world it
can mean whatever it means
needs to for the audience you can fill
it with whatever
specific content and then about like the
footloose thing mark says but does that
make rebellion a mainstream theme
is that recuperation i think is the term
and we might think about like the
breakfast club is as an example of that
too right it's like well you got your
jack you got your
right
prom queen girl you got your burnouts
you got your nerd and then whatever ali
sheedy was supposed to be you know the
weird girl or
yeah she was yeah she was the um
protogoth
yeah
yeah
very yeah totally goth did we we didn't
call it that back then did we no no
yeah so so i i think that's that's
quite true and i mean we did see movies
coming out as well
that sometimes heavy metal figured into
like horror movies
um one of the key themes is the adults
don't believe the teenagers about the
terrible danger like in nightmare on elm
street which you know eventually by
number three is gonna have a dawkins
song in their dream warriors uh my
favorite one
yeah what else uh oh there was that
there was that one that had um
fast way
did the uh
the soundtrack to it and it had ozzy
osbourne and gene simmons in it
i forget what that was called
an ozzy osbourne interestingly plays a
very stuffy
preacher type right
that's right
now here's an interesting point ken
makes maybe there's a distinction to be
made between authentic rebellion and
presentational rebellion that's actually
actually an act put on for purposes of
popularity and you know you could look
at twisted sisters um
um
approach and say where do they fit in
are they genuine rebellion
are they presentational and i think
that's the sort of thing that has to be
borne out by looking at like the larger
matrix if you just put together a band
and you put them up on stage and you
give them like rebellious names like
this guy is you know
axe murderer and this guy over here is
a puppy kicker or something or my
favorite william murder face oh right
from
from the band death clock yeah william
it's william murder face murder face
isn't it
yeah i mean death clock so i mean this
is totally off topic but death clock is
kind of a interesting thing for this
because they're always worried about
whether they're really metal or not
right
well you know
i don't want to jump off this point yet
because um ken has a great point you
know i always point to
you know
uh kiss is supposed to be the ultimate
party band you know and he had
you know the rant about we like cold gin
well they don't drink
you know like you know they weren't
partiers themselves i mean you know they
weren't uh
drug or alcohol users or they all but
you know they always talk about you know
in his rants uh zebedee like to get high
you know and yeah
i guess in the 70s you wouldn't know
that later it came out that they didn't
drink or do drugs you know it's funny
too with with uh kiss because i just
read this yesterday
um the song virgin killer which which
got uh the scorpions in a lot of trouble
and you know the album cover got banned
and stuff like that
they made that up as a spoof of kiss
they were touring with kiss
and um i forget exactly who it was i
think it might have it wasn't um
[Music]
maybe it was ulivon roth um but one of
them came in the back room and he's like
you know
messing around and and you know he made
up that that song virgin killer is
supposed to be a parody of kiss songs
because kiss songs are so over the top
right oh yeah and then it takes on a
life of its own you know and it gets
attributed to the scorpions as if you
know it's it's like their shtick now
mark says something interesting about
death clock here um death clock presents
a world where being a metal head is
rebellious it's economics and it is like
herd behavior too death block is like
the most important band in the world
uh people will engage in all sorts of
crazy behaviors to get to see them you
have a cabal of people that are worried
if death clocks album doesn't drop the
economy is going to go down
but they haven't
they haven't sold out as a result and it
is interesting because the most
important character
is not these clownish guys
in death clock it's their manager slash
attorney i forget his name but he's he
he you you realize that he's the real
thing behind death clock and it's he's
not rebellious at all
he's um very straight laced he's always
like all right guys now it's time for us
to get to recording quit [ __ ] around
ken says i think that there's the death
clock or self-aware to some extent or
even a little bit of self-parody um
yeah i mean there may be i'd have to go
back and look at the episodes i recently
watched my way through the entire thing
except for the final episode which i've
been saving
because it's 45 minutes long and a rock
opera
i think i think they're i mean among
some of them i guess nathan explosion
sometimes realizes that he's
he's being kind of uh silly
um
i would say that pickles
is probably the most
self-aware of the group
i you know that's that's my
view i mean william murderface has a lot
of like
whining and stuff like that because he's
the proverbial bassist and uh doesn't
get like the billing that everybody else
does except for toki
uh but it but it's mostly
off base whereas pickles seems to be a
little bit more
grounded even though he's like high all
the time
right
yeah i gotta go back and watch those
it's it's been a while um i think we
need to do an episode on
death clock as a metal band eventually
i mean yeah i mean you know the funny
thing is is
metalheads love the show
well i i wonder too who who else really
likes the show well that's interesting
i'd like to know the demographic it
ended up with we will have to do some
research on that yeah
um
so going on um one other song that we
definitely wanted to hit on i mentioned
this before running free now
running free is a little bit different
right it's not breaking the law we're
going to break the law because you jerks
won't give me a job it's not just a
generic we're not going to take it it's
more
this is what it's like to be
um
a kid just 16 a pickup truck i mean he
is out of money and out of luck he has
nowhere to call his own so what is the
response hit the gas here i go
and then it's this you know
anthemic i'm running free i'm running
free right and he winds up in an la jail
they don't have anything so he gets out
then he goes to a club
picks up a a woman
at the bottle top
whiskey dancing disco hop and then
somehow screws things up because now all
the boys are after me right
so he's he's gone into a place where he
doesn't really belong perhaps
and uh he's breaking the norms there and
that's it that's that's all there is to
the song but that song
it really does seem like a song of
rebellion doesn't it it was something we
could relate to so easily as
as kids even if we were like holding
down jobs and lived in a house and went
to school and that sort of thing well i
think that i mean i think that could be
part of it too if somebody feels you
know trapped in their suburban life
um
you know how many times you see adult
your adults say
i just want to get out i just want to go
away i just want to go away so it
doesn't have to be like um too literal
it could be
anybody that feels trapped
um although you know i i think there's
different reasons or levels of that but
you know like even the first bit of the
lyrics is definitely um you know there's
nothing for here got no place to call my
own
yeah it's interesting that they locate
it in a um
a different
continent right it's iron maiden singing
this putting it together in london
but it's it's in la it's in la right and
this is 1980 this is not like you know
heavy metal has exploded in la yet at
this
time um
yeah kind of curious because we have ken
here you know uh who came up in the the
new wave of british heavy metal
you know that song
must have had a significant impact it
was a single and then i forget what was
on the other side of it but it must have
gotten quite a bit of
play it's a short song it's um
you know it's easy to i mean they
weren't getting a ton of radio play but
it must have gotten a lot of uh
people responding to it you know well
you know i think back then weren't they
you know they were driving still driving
around in a
in a station wagon with you know
with records out of rushing
out of the back of their truck you know
whatever the car yeah yeah
um
well i think once that first album
dropped
um
there was already significant buzz about
iron maiden because of the sound house
tapes which are what you're you're
talking about there um
and it is i mean this is we're starting
to get into the weeds a bit with this
but one of the things we can talk about
with iron maiden is in terms of
vocalists like what happens when you go
from paul diana to
bruce dickinson
who does a great version of running free
but i you know there's there's some
things where paul diano
um
maybe he doesn't have the
pipes and the chops that bruce dickinson
did but for running free i think he did
you know i think that's a great song for
him he was much more of a you know bruce
dickinson's always you know been a
together person you know
you know he's a pilot
you know he's in shape they play soccer
but paul diana was a true
mess up and
you know he he might have been a better
person to deliver those lyrics
you know
as a broken fractured person you know
and then you relate i mean this is ethos
right you
you you look at someone and go that
guy's like me and he's singing about me
and then you know um
which is a whole other topic you know
yeah
so ken says maiden were going from pub
to pub playing gigs on stage is made of
broke up packing crates beer flying
everywhere great times interestingly i
don't remember running for you making
that much of a splash
interesting and then mark says bruce
does not have the character for the
theme though you can buy paul singing
that i don't know what do you do you
think that's that's right scott when it
when like so think about bruce dickinson
saying running free on live after death
yeah i didn't even
yeah i mean though even before like live
after death is the first maiden album i
got because i was looking for this song
i heard on a metal show once and of
course it was uh the trooper i didn't
know it was the truth okay yeah and my
friend had the tape and i went you know
they were all going to the beach and
instead of going to the beach because we
were on the cape on cape cod i was going
through his maiden tapes until i found
that song
and i found
it was it was track three right on uh so
so i found the trooper and then i like
it was preoccupied with getting that
album
and so but so i wore that album out but
the stuff that turned out to be diana
stuff was my least favorite on the album
that's interesting even like
phantom of the opera which bruce has the
no actually i did love the faint of the
eye okay right yeah yeah you're right
yeah i mean again we're going into the
weeds a little bit but
um like one song that i would think um
classic made and stuff that diano is
better on than than uh dickinson's wrath
child
what do you think
what did you say about dickinson and
rathchild yeah the song wrath child yeah
um
you know diana is the original singer
right dickinson has sung it probably
more times in his life because it's a
standard
but i think i kind of prefer deano on
that one yeah you know and i agree with
what mark is saying that's why i was
reading with mark's and it's it's you
know
the lyrics are different it's true and
yeah
you know when i watch the live at the
rainbow i'm sure everybody here is seen
live at the rainbow
um i'm totally convinced i think that's
just an amazing show it fires me up
diano's a mess and i love it and you
know
and you know uh
the rhythm section was on fire you know
like you and i always say they're a
little more punk then yeah and i think
that's has to do with their members so
you know when mark says bruce went to a
preppy school and it's clear in his
lyrics yeah i mean i love brewster
consider this stuff but it's kind of
like
um
i would say it's definitely has to do
with more rebellion in the diano era
than it does with the dickinson era yeah
interestingly um well it was ken who
suggested the prisoner is a song of
rebellion
um
social media and i think i think that
actually does fit you know
um
you know the
the lead-in from the show the prisoner
there's sort of a generic thing sort of
like the twisted sister right i'm not
going to be
pushed down by by you people and i'm not
a number i'm a free man yeah
so i think that kind of fits um one of
the things that that scott knives were
preparing for this did is kick around
some of the suggestions that people had
made and then
say well they're actually probably not
rebellion there's something else that's
closely related
and so one of the
um ones that came up a lot was black
sabbath's war pigs and then scott and i
started thinking and we said no it's not
actually rebellion we'll talk about why
but then we start looking at the black
sabbath catalog
i don't actually think that there's a
lot of straight out rebellion songs in
there
although they are to be into black
sabbath was kind of to be rebellious
right
in a way well that's what we you and i
had trouble with you know we're thinking
yeah black sabbath let's go there but i
kept going up no
yeah no but so yeah so ken points out
isn't war pig's an anti-vietnam song
yeah it is
but that's not enough to make it
rebellion it's like totally criticism of
the military industrial complex actually
you know um kind of cool sophisticated
ways of of doing that there's
condemnation
there's a divine judgment that takes
place but there's no
action on the part of the singer or or
anybody other than than god and the
devil that is is doing anything so it
definitely is so like rob says protest
versus rebellion it's definitely a
protest and a social criticism song
but i think in order to have rebellion
there's got to be
activity agency
doing something
and you know maybe that's part of what's
missing in a lot of uh the black sabbath
songs where they are criticizing
the culture and
it was a rebellion song it would
probably be sung in first person where
it's a soldier
and they're gonna escape from this
because they think it's wrong and
they're gonna you know uh do something
against the government you know i think
you know if they turned it that way uh
yeah that's how it's smoking about right
so rob asks is speaking truth to power a
form of rebellion or does it have to be
something other than speech i mean
that's a good question
um
i don't think that just criticizing is
is actually rebellion unless you're in a
situation
in which that's going to like get you
locked up
and nobody was about to lock up black
sabbath for
war pigs
doesn't rebellion
require
action or
well i think i think rob's got a good
point if you're in a totalitarian
society like the act of so if black
sabbath had gone behind the iron curtain
and yeah and one of the things we're
going to talk about a little bit later
is they had these lists of like bands
that were forbidden in the soviet union
right which included like ufo you know
for example
um i mean they're pretty extensive so to
to do that behind the iron curtain or to
like go to you know iran during the
iranian revolution if black sabbath had
played there they're playing i don't
know they wouldn't have been war pigs it
would have been something else that
would have been an act of rebellion
i don't think that playing it
in the united states or in um you know
the uk at the time or france or other
parts of the world that were more free
is it's protests but i don't i don't see
it as rebellion myself um
yeah now ken says i don't think black
sabbath ever did actual rebellion
even things like fairies wear boots as
criticism yeah i mean fairies wear boots
is kind of interesting because you do
have a character there right and he's
he's getting a hard time from an older
guy
you dirty hippies you know kind of thing
uh mark says critiquing what we suffer
as championing what we do passivity
versus activity with the would activity
be rebellion i think there's something
there yeah i think that now
we're not going to take it
it's an active thing breaking the law
running free these are
these are um
action-oriented even though you don't
know what the hell the action is like
running free running free and doing what
well you know driving around my pickup
truck
yeah exactly partying
so rob says that also makes me wonder
about whether one needs something like a
coherent account of what one is doing in
order to engage in rebellion
i think that's important and i think
that there's some songs that mention
rebellion
or being a rebel
but they don't offer enough content
for it um so anyway like it's a black
sabbath you know another one that we
thought of disturbing the priest right
off of the uh born-again album because
you're you're actively disturbing the
priest
um
but
it's not really about that i mean the
choruses were disturbing the priest
um
and it's actually based in like
apparently they were disturbing a vicar
when they were recording their album out
there in 1983
but it's really about a struggle between
the religious figure of the priest and
the devil and the narrator just wants to
be free of both so he says the devil and
the priest can't exist if one goes away
it's like the battle of the sun and moon
and night and day and then he says watch
out for religion when he the devil gets
to to near
so it's not really a rebellion song it's
more of an escape song right
um
yeah and i just want to say that you
know there's some good points here
um
here's the thing about like we're not
going to take it for example yeah
they don't have to put
the the point of these songs that we're
talking about some of them are kind of
vague right like will
you know and don't you need something to
depart from well that's what the
listener
puts that's what the listener feels
you know the listener we're not going to
take it it's like you know i
misunderstood well that's enough for me
to go yeah well you know
my teacher you know keeps you know doing
this or my parents keep grounding me and
then you take we're not going to take it
to your specific situation i think it
works in songs um
it and and the video content helps to
give you exactly what they're talking
about we're not going to take it is
about oppressive parents you know
which was a common thing because you
know
um
yeah with mtv coming out i guess and and
and um
yeah
it was kind of like you're watching this
stuff and then you know all the talk
shows like phil dawn
kids are watching can you believe it you
know
so
yeah so
um rob says to be an act of rebellion it
doesn't have to be coherent or even
aimed in a particular direction i mean i
think it kind of helps
to have specificity but it you know if
you want to have like a big song like
we're not gonna take it you don't want
it too specific like scott said you can
kind of ignore the verses and just focus
on the chorus right
um
so
yeah um now ken says i would i would
posit protest becomes rebellion at the
point where passivity becomes activity
and i i think that there's something
there too
another song that we considered
triumph fight the good fight
beautiful song it's an anthem right
um i think we all know the chorus
knowing the
other lyrics uh maybe not so much it's
very inspirational
but it's not really rebellion it's it's
about rejecting the wrong perspectives
you know there's you think a little more
money will buy your soul some rest
there's also solidarity keep up your
spirit keep up your faith i'm counting
on you you know what you've got to do
so it sounds rebellious but it's really
more about like
how to get by in
a crappy situation where you're going to
be challenged it's even more encouraging
than rebelling right
it's more of an interview
yeah
inspiring or
i mean right now could it be turned to
the purposes of rebellion maybe
um you know you're you're up against
some some pretty bad
people
and now you know you play triumphs fight
the good fight every moment it could be
part of a rebellion but i don't think
it's rebellious itself right another one
that goes back to this uh this thing
about um
so rob doesn't it doesn't have to be
coherent or even aimed in a particular
direction
wasp has a song called rebel in the fdg
which means effing
degenerates generation right
um
it's just a hot mess of a song i i love
it
um musically lyrically it's garbage
quite frankly so i i don't think it's a
rebellion song
um and even if it was i'm a rebel in the
generation of degenerate so what i'm a
rebel against rebels yeah you know
okay
they got to their meeting room table and
said okay
now we need to rebel against the
rebellious well and that album
interestingly that's when that's when
wasp abandoned the stage show with like
the chainsaws and
flames and they they pared down and you
can see interviews with blackie lawless
where he's like yeah we wanted this to
be a lot more political we don't want to
distract from our message and there's a
lot you know stuff about the
ronald reagan the neutron bomber and
things along those lines in there mark
says i don't listen to nobody's rules
not even my own
yeah another one that we looked at um
that was was kind of um similar
um motley cruz public enemy number one
public enemy number one but it's not a
rebellion song
because it's just a title
exactly it'd make you think it is
but it's just about you know do you know
what it's like to be wanted being under
the gun being young and then it just
says i'm public enemy number one over
and over again without any proof
provided you know
anybody can come along and say i'm a
rebel i'm public enemy number one
uh another great example of of this is
van halen's atomic punk right
um he's a victim of the science age
child of the storm he's a ruler of the
netherworlds nobody rules these streets
at night like me the atomic punk
that's all cool and it's it's a great
song and it's it's fun to imagine but
he's not rebelling against anything he's
he's actually kind of running the show
uh mark says there's there's been a
distinction so far between rebellion is
framed in
new wave of british heavy metal songs
versus us glam would you say that bears
out further well so that's actually a
good segue into another glam
band from l.a lizzie borden
me against the world i would say that is
a
preeminent song of rebellion right
it starts out
it's just me against the world
and
the
the bridge before the chorus is i am for
real you don't know what i feel my
strength is in my
will i can't wait i won't be second rate
in for the kill and then it's it's me
against the world me against the world
right just being repeated over and over
again and it's it's pretty generic it's
not saying what he's rebelling against
but it's pretty clear that he is you
know setting himself against the world
so well
rebellion has to be an act you can feel
isolated and misunderstood but unless
you're
taking action there's actually no
rebellion
yeah so that means to feel isolated or
um
misunderstood but just wallowing in that
is definitely not rebellion
yeah
i mean there's a lot of
kind of
defiant language in it i you know if i'm
an outcast i'm not the last i'm gonna
have my say they'll never take me alive
i'm gonna make them all pay those those
are well yeah
but
you're right
i'll make them pay it's not i'm making
them pay right
anybody can say that they're going to do
that right right
so i think we have to think about what
what actually really goes into or
constitutes rebellion we talked a little
bit about agency
um
and you also have to have opposition you
can't be a rebel without something to
rebel against
um
but you so you know i guess you could
say it's relative to what you're
rebelling against um some sort of
stronger earlier power or authority or
order or you could be against imposition
of a new force that's taking away
things that you've enjoyed before
so
there's that and i kind of think
now i i'm curious to what everyone has
to say about this
can you be a rebel entirely
on your own or does it have to at least
implicitly involve a larger identity or
solidarity so i mean you can use me
language but if we can identify it with
it then there's a we there
right it's us it's not me against the
world it's us against the world
um
that seems to be important
what do you think
i mean
i mean you could well you could be a
rebel it doesn't have to be a we i mean
we would be um
uh
well there's a different word for that
well what would you say if a bunch of us
were rebelling that would be like a
cause more so or yeah then it attains a
kind of
the status of like a movement right a
movement yeah that's what i'm looking
for so ken says it's absolutely
impossible to rebel as an individual i
would say for example soviet dissidents
uh rob asked was socrates a rebel i mean
i'm i'm not saying that that in the
lyrics they're
using we
i'm saying that in so far as
the song could get picked up and used as
a way of identifying it there's sort of
an implicit we
involved well in metal it makes sense
doesn't it because this is
this is the group that understands you
yeah
you know metalheads i don't know about
anybody else but in my school we found
each other
and uh there's an unspoken you know
uh
i was just thinking you know we usually
found each other the smoking area
you know
when i was in high school was like the
last year they had a smoking lounge okay
like going away with the smoking lounge
um
which is funny because you know uh once
they went away but he's like they had a
smoking lounge yeah
the schools used to have them
yeah we used to it was totally off topic
but when i was in college here in
wisconsin you could smoke in public
buildings and so
you couldn't smoke in class
but as soon as class ended all the
smokers would light up in the classroom
including the professor
and then like the classroom would just
fill with smoke you know
there were some buildings that were off
limits like the science building you
couldn't smoke
you know you're gonna screw things up
but the humanities
the humanities building was was awful
for the non-smokers and then they passed
this law and it was really funny because
you know i want to talk about rebellion
so smokers are kind of belly acres you
know you're taking air rights and all
that and they're they don't care about
anybody else's rights to like not get
you know not stink you know yeah so um
they passed this law and then you know
the school said okay no more smoking in
any of the buildings on campus you have
to go outside and we're like oh this is
terrible you know
and within like three days
suddenly this haze that was always there
in old main disappeared it dissipated
and we're like holy crap you can like
really see in here and then we started
thinking wow it must have really been
awful for the non-smokers
so ken says being a metal fan in the
early days definitely involved a sense
of belonging to the metalhead community
and i think that now it's still true
today yeah but i think it's kind of
changed it's kind of morphed right
um
and uh mark says by the sheer fact the
singer sings to an audience you could
argue the singer sings about rebellion
with the intent of connecting
that's interesting yeah if you sing
about your crappy
life
and who you don't like because they're
they're like
putting their boot on you
are you like automatically reaching
other people yeah
well i can't think of any well you know
it's funny we're talking about this era
because
uh the the metal
and of course that we've talked about
there's you know 500 subcategories but i
don't hear any anybody talking about
rebellion i don't hear anybody you mean
in lyrics or lyrics that's what i mean
yeah like the students will bring stuff
in all the time
and um
it's a lot of dream sequence stuff right
you know or or um okay
uh
fantasy i should say um yeah but you
know it's not the
i don't hear people chanting anything i
don't know
you know it was uh
i think like you know
what you said uh
who said it that in the early days it
was definitely a unified mark
mark said like in the early days of
metal there was definitely
so i think you know in the early days
you know i always go back to you go to
the mall and we used to tell parents you
know we're gonna go see a movie but we
just walk around the mall in circles
but
you would walk by somebody with you know
a triumph patch on their jacket and you
go hey man yeah dude you going to see
when they come here and you know
instantly
you were you know you didn't have to
introduce each other you know it's funny
i was at summerfest a couple weeks ago
to see
um
we were there for like a new wave night
so we saw
um
howard jones and um
modern english and a couple other bands
and i we were walking around
and i had my uh saxon shirt on and you
know i mean i don't have any
band shirts for you know bands like
modern english all i have is metal stuff
and so a guy came up to me and he and
he's like he was clearly like super
drunk
and he's like you know he wanted a fist
bump and i was like okay you know yeah
and he's like saxon man i love them you
know what's your favorite album and he's
tr you start starting up a conversation
with me and it's funny too because the
guy did not know that saxon is still
around still touring still putting out
new albums and he his mind was blown
by that sort of but you know seeing the
the the logo was enough to kind of do it
for him rob says oh this is good
yesterday i was walking around the park
with a metal t-shirt some kid had a
skateboard flash me the devil horns
so there is hope for a new generation
right that is that that's kind of
excellent to
to read that's awesome you know it
really
the interesting thing about the
priesthood
um
um
uh gosh oh yeah so
on this whole thing about rebellion and
togetherness and and kind of the
the culture
um steve harris
tells a story
that on one of the tours they you know
he steve harris is a big journey fan
yeah and he said we would play journey
in our pa music like four or five songs
and the crowd would start booing it
and um
interesting kind of think about it
you're you know with your bunch of metal
heads and stuff and wait this isn't our
people this isn't our music this isn't
you know and to get actually angry the
journey's being played
and um well i told you when wasted
opened
um when they came out that really kind
of almost survivor-like pop record they
opened for maiden on the somewhere in
time tour that i saw and everybody was
booing them and of course that made
that made uh steve harris angry yeah
because his hero's up there you know
love hate got booed off stage uh on uh
when i saw iron maiden in madison like
91 or 90
um
they got to play five songs and everyone
was like get the hell out of here we're
here to hear maiden you know so
it's a it's a yeah it's a it's a um
it's a tight-knit community
that's true and and it's interesting
because i i guess it kind of shows you
that like there's like the being
rebellious and we we look at these
people kind of romantically like oh they
must be very open and stuff like that
not necessarily maybe the rebellion can
be very
directed and everything outside of that
you know screw them you know or here's
here's your here's your room that you
wouldn't let me in so we've created our
own and you're not allowed in ours i
don't know i mean
i think that happens um you know so
rebellion can be rebellion against like
hierarchy and then new hierarchies can
get very easily
established right
um and you know if we think about going
back to like what is rebellion there's a
number of different values or themes
that it could be organized around um one
of the most abstract is the music itself
the right to rock you know and that's
what um we're not gonna take it is is
about in given the video right
uh it could be hedonism um you know
we're gonna party a lot and that's how
we rebel we get drunk and high we screw
we break stuff we dance you know yeah
that could be
the keel album
the right to rock wasn't that yeah that
gene simmons produced right that's right
yeah yeah i mean simmons did a lot of
bat there's a lot of stuff in the
background him and dio you know a lot of
stuff in in la with different bands well
d and gene simmons was kind of at the
beginning of van halen right he was the
one who um
got them to produce their first demo
yeah you know that's that's pretty big
and their demo wasn't like three tracks
it was like 20 tracks
yeah um what else i mean lifestyle
you're not going to keep me from wearing
my denim and leather you're not going to
get me to cut my long hair
that could be part of rebellion
being against
parental or educational or political
authority
criminality law breaking
fighting aggression that sort of stuff
and i suppose you could even say that
like referencing some fantasy stuff or
the occult or satanism because a lot of
bands referenced um
uh satan without being satan worshipers
you know they'd say well it's you know
it's a way for me to
to uh
stick it to the
the authorities
um i think all of those are themes that
that show up um
going back to the maiden thing ken says
ironically some people complain about
maiden
using the ufo song as their concert
intro track being oblivious as to who
ufo were yeah i mean so lights out right
is is
um uh i think the track in question and
um yeah it's interesting when you when
you look at this is a whole different
topic influence right people are like oh
black sabbath the most influential metal
band yeah they were except that on iron
maiden arguably a massively influential
band you asked them who their heroes
were
and uh bruce dickinson doesn't say
geezer butler he says pete way you know
and then you know um
or steve harris
steve harris yeah bruce dickinson's uh
sorry bruce dickinson says ian gillan he
that was the person he wanted to be not
not ozzie i mean who the hell would want
to be obviously right well lights out in
london that's such a rocking tune it's
burning yeah that's a great tune and i
didn't realize that um people didn't
like it
as is the
they're using it right before they go on
stage you mean that yeah exactly the way
that judas priests uses uh black sabbath
war pigs it has become a popular thing
for bands these days to like have a
intro track that's the same everywhere i
think yep
so
well let's let's talk about a few more
uh songs be you know we're
we've really like run through the time
quickly um except i'm a rebel is that a
is that a rebellions song i mean it
certainly
seems simple
right it's the title for starters
you know and interestingly that wasn't
originally by accept it was an ac dc
song
that except took and then did a um
you know essentially a cover of
um
it's kind of generic you know i'm a
rebel don't you know it they're all
laughing at me they say i'm a danger to
the public
um i'm just the product of a screwed up
world it's it's it's there's not an
awful lot of content there you know
so i don't know about that one but it
you know it's at least got rebel and
it's its name as does queen's right
chemical youth rebellion right
which is hard it's hard to make out the
lyrics on that one when you listen to it
i i listened to it just the other day
and
when they were asked about it um here we
go chris degarno
said
this was about 20th century youth living
in the atomic age it was also a play on
the technological ecological aspect of
the day we were living in at the time
it's a song about feeling rebellious
i don't know if there was really a
general theme to it it was more of a
hodgepodge of all these little sentences
that made up a modern modern-day picture
now when you when you hear that
even though it's mentioning rebellion i
don't know that it's a rebellion song
ken says uh not sure about except german
thrash came from a distinct distinctly
different origin than us thrash i mean
one of the songs
that does come up that we should talk
about
as a rebellion song with accept is later
i mean i'm a rebel is the title of their
second album
and this one is the title of an album
balls to the wall
that's a rebellion song
you know
it's uh
so the bridge part is watch the dam
they're going to break their chains you
can't stop them they're coming to get
you
and then you'll get your balls to the
wall who's getting their balls to the
wall the oppressors those who keep other
people in chains you know too many
slaves in this world die by torture and
pain too many people do not see they're
killing themselves going insane too many
people do not know bondage is over the
whole human race they believe slaves
always lose and this fear keeps them
down so he's saying let's not let the
fear keep us down because then you know
in the bridge part
come on man let's stand up all over the
world let's plug a bomb in everyone's
ass
okay that's pretty rebellious
right if they don't keep us alive we're
going to fight for our right build a
wall with the bodies of the del the dead
and you're saved make the world scared
come on show me the sign of victory now
if you've ever been to an accept or an
udo concert
at that moment when they're playing that
song because they never don't play balls
to the wall yeah like the whole place is
erupting you know
you've got that you know
everybody's singing together
you're right
um
that one is definitely a rebellion song
so maybe i'm a rebel not so much balls
to the wall
uh
you know
clearly whatever you want to say is it
about the proletariat is it about you
know the average person is it about the
people who've been shut out
um it's sort of like you know if if you
took breaking the law and then you blew
it up into a giant we
right
yeah right
well that's where we it comes to uh
it becomes a movement or a cause or uh
whatever whatever you know yeah
we're all involved
you know there's another song that my
wife and i
use as a joke um off the same album
which is not a rebellion song and is one
that sort of like reinforces hierarchy
losers and winners
right
like whenever
my wife andy complains about something
not always but often i'll say write a
letter
you'll feel better
writing a letter is not an act of
rebellion generally right yeah
and he's made in the song except they're
making fun of the people who write
letters because they're impotent you
know
so
you'll feel better right yeah yeah right
yeah same album you know uh
so um you know we here's another one
that we should talk about what about
queens reich's revolution calling a
revolution rebellion not maybe the
exactly the same thing but
is revolution calling a song of
rebellion um in the narrative right he's
gonna tie in with his doctor x the man
with the cure
and he's gonna get screwed over by him
yeah but he's joining a movement of what
seems to be rebels but at this point he
doesn't know he's going to get screwed
over that's right he's hopeful he's
he's hopeful and pissed off right
um he's like i'm tired of all the
[ __ ] they keep selling me on tv
about the communist plan
you know um i used to think only
america's way was right but now the holy
dollar rules everybody's life you know
and then the the the chorus is
revolution calling
you there's a revolution calling gotta
make a change gotta push it on through
okay so that sounds pretty
active
active yeah
um
is that a revolution song what do you
think or not a revolutionary a rebellion
song
well
yeah i mean
in it we have specifics of what's
disagreed about
yeah that's true you know
um well so this is different than uh
the past tunes which were simply um
you know well what do you mean you're
you're rebelling well i'm gonna drive
around in the truck you know like or i'm
gonna you know this is this is this is
more of a um
revolution now we've moved into instead
of me it's it's a big cause it's a
little more
political it's more
specific
uh but it starts off the story somebody
that's
angry that somebody's going to
join some kind of cause because they're
angry and the the goal is to make a
choice and it's not you know
revolutions are usually not pretty
yeah so rob says the difference between
revolution and rebellion one of
perspective and then ken says maybe
every revolution is a rebellion but not
every rebellion involves revolution yeah
because
revolutions transform things right um
i mean if if they're not successful
they're just a revolt
if they don't somehow
right right modify the the situation
that you're in
and like different you know
rebelling against your parents by
sneaking out the window to go smoke
butts with your friend
you know and
as opposed as opposed to taking over the
household yourself right seizing the
finances yeah that would be a revolution
or or the government you know a little
different
yeah
so here's here's here's one to consider
is alice cooper schools out a song of
rebellion
um
i mean it's certainly rebellious and it
got turned into a kind of
uh as he says you know like like an
anthem for the end of school he actually
said something really kind of funny
about it
um
which is
when we did schools out i knew we had
just done the national anthem i'd become
the francis scott key of the last day of
school and then he said it's amazing how
everyone relates to that song and mostly
the teachers the teachers are so sick of
the kids at that point
so maybe like in in 72 when he came out
with it the teachers are these much more
repressive types and um i mean we played
it when we you know we left the parking
lot you know every
85 86 you know
but now we have teachers that grew up on
that and maybe they're like i can't wait
to get these damn kids out of my hair
and have a summer to myself
yeah actually rob what do you think
about that uh you're a professor you
know
um
is that something that you would play
when they leave your class well it
depends if he's an adjunct or not
rob says every f in year yeah so
another one that we were going to look
at um judas priest's parental guidance
and this gets us into the heart of the
counter response
to heavy metal rebellion
parental guidance is directly aimed at
the pmrc
which um those who don't know you know
who are
watching um this was a
group that was sort of a watchdog group
it had a lot of political clout behind
it tipper gore was in it
a few other big politicians wives and
they got to
start you know congressional hearings on
heavy metal that dee snyder
showed up for and you know spoke very
eloquently and
so you know the parental guidance song
is saying we don't need no parental
guidance here and it's very much about
music every day you scream at me to turn
the music low
if you keep on screaming you'll make me
deaf you know you chew me out because i
stay out late until your three-piece
suit comes back and date get one thing
straight you know and
it's it's you know
is there real real rebellion here is or
is it just pushback i i think it's
maybe not real rebellion like breaking
the law but just kind of criticism
you know ozzy osbourne too was great at
having songs where he's like essentially
whining about how misunderstood he is
right there's no agency there you know
the problem with parental guidance when
it came out it was undermined by how
corny the song itself was okay i mean
well that's interesting so
it wasn't like a great metal riff it was
just kind of this it sounded like this
chorus they just threw together like
they were singing to some commercial or
something remember when they came out
like we all were just like oh god this
is terrible
yeah so
this is one that we didn't think about
uh rob is pointing or ken is pointing
out uh metal churches start the fire
rebellion by the younger generation
against the older generation
that's been perfect yeah yeah and i mean
that was that was an album where judas
priest probably lost some of their
street cred you know turbo
yeah well and and you know some of the
songs were a bit um
yeah
it was not their strongest album but
that was on the radio on people oh yeah
but but i remember every time it came on
it was just like i'm not a priest fan
any fan anymore it was it was it was a
tough song to hear and i thought it was
just kind of like you know you guys you
know they're not in it anymore sure
you're saying no parental guidance but
it's not this isn't metal and i don't
and i don't believe you
so
switching back to the pmrc one of the
one of the things that was kind of
interesting about that was that they
were trying to claim or at least some of
the experts were trying to claim that
rebellion was right at the heart of of
metal and i think they were mixing up
rebellion with rebelliousness
um
because you know one of these they
actually had a music professor joe
stussy who testified
that um you know the songs were focused
on and he had a whole bunch of things
rebellion violence substance abuse
perversion s m
satanism and you know this is what led
to the pmrc having their filthy 15. and
it's interesting because i looked these
up the other day
so of the filthy 15 nine of them are
metal songs
um judas priests eat me alive motley
cruise bastard ac dc let me put my love
into you twisted sister we're not going
to take it
wasps animal [ __ ] like a beast def
leppard now this is a def leppard's high
and dry saturday night for drug use you
know
uh merciful fates into the coven black
sabbaths trashed and venoms possessed
and then they had like categories like
and you could you could have several
categories one of them managed to get
like three different categories
sex violence language drug alcohol use
and occult rebellion was not one of
their categories in there i'll also
mention too that of the other six in the
filthy 15 other than prince all the rest
of them are female artists which might
show a kind of misogyny and desire to
control all of them are sexy songs you
know madonna
um
uh i'm blanking on the name of the the
woman who was very uh closely associated
with prince she got in there as well
wendy
i think so and then and then like uh
cindy laupers um shebop was in there
you know
um well you know what's weird you know
that that they would bring a music
professor in
that's why what what does a musical well
well it establishes a certain kind of
credibility no idea absolutely not i
mean well not for us but for the general
public right you know you've got a
professor it's an expert witness yeah
but wouldn't you get a linguist expert
or wouldn't you get like a you know
something to do with the lyric content
you're not having somebody analyze the
chord progressions or
talk about the melodies and that's where
a musician or music professor would come
in if you're dealing with the content of
the tune you know
especially a music professor would are
they an expert on this kind of music i
mean there's so much wrong with that i
mean that's a it's almost like this is a
whole non-starter now
yeah i i i mean for us yes i think for
if you're trying to just like put on a
show
i think it it works you know
um robert walzer who's whose book i i
brought up um he did an analysis himself
to see if this guy's claims were valid
and he actually said these these themes
are kind of uncommon
um another psychologist uh analyzed
lyrics from 115 metal songs and found
that the top three messages
were in fact about um violence angst and
protest but not rebellion as such you
know so it's interesting that they
they use the specter of rebellion you
know your kids are going to turn into
rebels i mean or or they're going to
turn into devil worshipers which i guess
is pretty close and if you think about
rivera's um
geraldo rivera's expose and that was in
what like 87
yeah 2687.
that's that's all he hammered on is your
kids are going to turn into a bunch of
like you know
um
dangerous serial killer types because of
listening to this this awful music you
know it's hard to believe that he put it
across with a straight face now ken
brings up uh megadeth and we do have one
megadeath song in the mix
they've always been a very political
band though possibly more commentary and
criticism than rebellion
i think peace cells who's dying or peace
cells but who's buying i almost said
who's dying
um
i i want to say that's that's a song of
rebellion but it's a song of rebellion
within limits
he it's set up in such a way that it's
what do you mean x
um i fulfill this condition what do you
mean i don't believe in god i talk to
him every day what do you mean i don't
support your system i go to court when i
have to so i'm being rebellious but i'm
being rebellious within the limits
what do you mean i don't pay my bills
why do you think i'm broke
[Laughter]
um and then
i love this line if there's a new way
i'll be the first in line but it better
work this time i think that is
inherently a
a political statement
you know it's not just about economics
it's not just about you know
culture it's saying listen
um
i'm cool with trying something new
but quit bullshitting me around about
how it's gonna be so great when clearly
that's not the case you know so it is it
is a rebellious song but it's also a
rebellious song that's like holding
people accountable
which i think is very different it's one
thing to be like i'm going to throw a
brick in your window and kick your teeth
in because i don't like you know the
economy that i'm in it's another thing
to say listen
i'll put up with some of your [ __ ]
but i'm not putting up with all of it
and i want to see some i want to see
some response on your part you know i
think that's what's going on so ken says
that could definitely be considered to
be actively rebellious as opposed to
being commentary yeah yeah
i think that makes sense i mean
some of megadeth songs are also
they're aggressive they're they're
rebellious but they're not rebellious
against an authority they're more like
you know you let me down i don't like
you you know
yeah i mean when you get things like the
queen's with the operation mind crime in
this world we're getting to uh
a little more thought-provoking
you know this it's less of a
you know a chant or a
that kind of thing you know like where
um
or an anthem i that's the word i'm
looking okay yeah that's some anthem but
like you know you really have to kind of
dig in and read a little more than like
when i said before it's like i remember
the chorus and that was good enough for
me
yeah yeah
here's another one to think about a lot
of people brought up wasps i want to be
somebody
is that really a rebellion song
um
or is it a song about wanting to be on
the top you know
the the verse you say you don't want to
starve or take the table crumbs at fall
you don't want to beg and plead at all
you don't want no nine to five your
fingers to the bone you don't want the
rock piles bloody stones but then it's
you got to be up high where the whole
world's watching me because i got the
guts to be somebody
i want to be somebody be somebody soon i
want to be somebody be somebody too and
then what does that look like i want
shiny cars and dirty money lots of rock
and roll i'll live in fame and die in
flames i'm never getting old so this
this totally imaginary hedonistic
lifestyle
i don't know that that's rebellion it's
more like i want to get mine jack you
know
yeah it's
i mean to blow it down it sounds like
wishing
somebody's like you know
daydreaming about their life
you know
so it's it's fantasy fulfillment it's
fantasy fulfillment because there's not
there's no action involved we know what
you want but how you're going to get it
is our first thing and then you think
well i'll tell you what i'm going to do
i'm going to go burn down the church
down the road that's what i'm going to
do or yeah i'm going to go you know
uh
okay so ken says i describe it more as
ambition rather than rebellion and and
you could in fact fulfill that ambition
without rebelling against anything you
get your record deal
and you know you go on your your tours
and you know sing your songs and stuff
like that
now here's something interesting from
rob if a song or album is a sustained
highly cognitive critique and call to
action
still rebellion or does it cease being
rebellion at a certain level of
sophistication well that's that's what i
was thinking about before
because
rebellion
on the surface doesn't it sound just
like kind of uh
so he says is mark's communist manifesto
uh rebel rebellion lit
um
yeah i mean
maybe i mean if we're talking musically
it would have to be something like a
cons a concept album right and the
closest thing that we come to that is
maybe queens reich's operation mind
crime
where it turns out that he's been
totally suckered
and the rebellion is just part of the
same basic structure right
um
yeah that's kind of a pessimistic uh
take on it isn't it well that's
interesting about marx
um
yeah
you know so we we we and by this i mean
andy and i saw rage against the machine
at alpine valley just
last saturday
and it was very striking because you
know rage against the machine you think
okay a you know
a genre metal band um
and
you know the the guitarist is doing some
weird stuff on his guitar all the time
um and all their songs are basically
about you know
um criticizing authority you know
sometimes it's about the police
sometimes it's about uh economic
structures there's also that song uh
where you know the the chorus is you
know fu i won't do what you tell me
that's pretty yeah yeah
and
rage against the machine is not very
rebellious as rage against the machine i
mean for one thing
zero engagement with the audience
whatsoever a huge crowd of like i don't
know maybe 20 000 people
and the only thing the singer said to
acknowledge the presence of the audience
he looked out and he's like oh [ __ ] you
know
and
zero like talking back and forth
just lots and lots of songs with slogans
and then they would put stuff up on this
really cool screen behind them you know
some images where somebody's you know
oppressed and somebody's a police person
and then they'll be like a slogan but
you're like this is just pure commodity
well that's it
yeah
i was just gonna say the same thing you
know we don't believe you i think that's
like you know
it's kind of like when somebody yeah
it's kind of like uh
if you're not like engaging with the
crowd like you know this is
you you've come to hear this message or
we're going to share this then it
becomes a commodity yeah
ken says it's commercial rather than
authentic yeah and i don't believe you
yeah and they're making tons and tons of
money off of you know this
get back together tour um because they
haven't they hadn't played together for
a while and this was by the way this was
the beginning of their tour
so if there was any place where you'd
think they'd be like create creating a
wii
uh with engagement with the audience
that would be the place but
yeah just didn't happen at all you know
and this this so this leads to a good
sort of thing to wrap up
is it possible to remain rebellious over
time or is this something by its nature
that's not lasting i
started you know talking about
back in the late 80s um van halen you
know saying we're going to stop the
concert if you don't stop tearing up the
grass here and then people were like
that's not um that's not metal man
that's not rock and roll you you've sold
out you know yeah and uh obviously it's
kind of funny what would david lee roth
have done if he was there would he have
been like tear it up you know
party um sammy hangar was a little bit
more mature and responsible
and
i mean like i'm gonna say somewhere in
time tour there were signs all over from
maiden
and they said
don't destroy the stuff or we can't come
back and play which is different right
yeah yeah that's different because it's
like we want to
essentially we want to come and rock for
you but they won't let us come back and
rock if you destroy everything rather
than we're going to stop the show if you
don't stop throwing chairs around you
know yeah you know this you know i'm you
know you will see uh
uh
you will see um
bruce dickinson yell at people in shows
which i think is hysterical you know
like there's people smoking pot in front
of him and he's he's he laid into them
because he has to take drug tests
right yeah yeah
i mean that kind of makes sense right it
does yeah but anyways i didn't mean to
totally go off but
so rob says all rebels need a they yeah
so they need somebody to
to um
push against ken says i think
historically rebellions have either been
successful or have been crushed and yeah
so if the rebels are successful can they
keep rebelling
at a certain point you know
some of these songs right
you're like well i don't know you're a
multi-millionaire
i don't and you're 70 years old i don't
know that you're really a rebel anymore
um
so it's it's it's a good
thing to uh
well that come on
that comes you have to relate to the
artist you know um okay i agree with
that like if if you know if you're you
know
it's harder to take you know a
multi-million dollar
artist singing about inequality
you know like as a rebellion kind of
thing um
you know rather than so a great example
when when skid row who don't even have
sebastian bach anymore sing youth gone
wild
which was big when they were youth
in in 89
uh but now it's 2022.
um
they're not really
talk about the youth gone wild what
youth are they talking about it's always
uh
sebastian sang it you know in first
person too like or as a wii right yeah
and it's like you know um but you know
in your 50s can you still could you
still say that
um or you know you know people people
change from age 18 to 50 as far as their
values and you know hopefully over time
we don't still have our same views as
when we were 18
to some day i mean looking at myself
thank god because uh yeah same i was
pretty stupid back then
yeah i mean you know uh there is
something to be say
said about um
you know that it's it's it's a topic for
another
um
discussion i think but you know
is it right that the content changes as
the bands get older is it is it
appropriate or are you just gonna you
want the same album as from when they
wrote when they were 21 at 57 or you
know yeah you know i think a great
example of this
with with some significant contrast
right
so
um judas priest turbo and iron maiden
somewhere in time both get criticized
by metal fans
at the time for using too many um synths
right too much keyboard too much guitar
synth stuff like that
but
musically what's going on
you know it's just kind of more of the
same for judas priest on that album um
lyrically at least
somewhere in time is
you know
the loneliness of the long distance
runner you wouldn't have heard that on
peace of mind
or
number of the beast let alone iron
maiden right so there's some significant
evolution taking place
conceptually lyrically
as opposed to just musically in in that
getting older not not growing old but
getting older getting a bit more mature
you know
yeah yeah and you know it it comes down
to do you want the same album being made
or do you it's like you know i was yeah
yeah i always defend robert plant he
can't sing that stuff anymore he can't
sing the old zeppelin stuff anymore and
what he's doing now fits his voice and
fits his age and he's writing about
stuff he's like look you know i was a
crazy 21 year old and like i had no
boundaries and and i didn't know a lot
about life and that's why it's what you
got that was an authentic performance
he's you know if he if even if he had
the pipes out that's not an authentic
performance i don't know
that's a that's a whole other debate
well this is a good place to
to close this up
we're so glad that that uh
we could be joined um thanks scott for
joining us and but also uh mark and rob
and ken bringing a lot of expertise and
some great questions
um it looks like this new platform
although it has a few glitches is
probably what we're gonna stick with
yeah so
yeah um
we don't have a topic picked yet for
next time but we'll uh we'll kick around
some ideas so thanks to everybody and
really glad that all of you could join
us for this
take care
you